bonsoir patrick mennucci bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france un
commentaire sur les résultats à
marseille qui sont encore en ballottage
et évidemment les résultats définitifs
ne seront connus que tard ce soir ou
demain matin
bonsoir maya dit bonsoir écouter ses
satisfactions gamme de voir les
héritiers de jacobs côté la peine s'il
ya une deuxième tour et à quel moment il
y aura lieu mais il me semble que la
possibilité pour tout et avec bangaly
devrait permettre de la ville soit
emmené vers d'autres chemins que ce demi
à deux robes qui était conduit par jean
claude gaudin depuis les années alors
patrick mennucci a marseille il ya eu
des mesures d'hygiène qui ont été prises
comme partout en france dans les bureaux
de vote
mais visiblement dans votre ville il y a
eu quelques soucis qu'est ce que
pouvaient nous nous en dire des jeux les
suffisait de bureaux de vote sont les
soucis que nous avons même cette ville
c'est à dire une désorganisation extrême
des services publics et du service
public municipal
il y avait la plupart des bleus
n'avaient pas de gel les conditions
n'étaient pas au pin etc il faut
peut-être que les français on découvre
on repère dans la gestion calamiteuse
après les époux moment de la rue
d'aubagne mais ça s'est pas améliorée
depuis
c'est les mêmes gens qui dirigent et ils
sont aussi incapable d'organiser
correctement
une situation qui nous est imposée pas
qu'on va les russes que de deux monnaies
de facebook
pourquoi n'y avait il pas de gel par
exemple
le patriote je n'ai pas de réponse la
réponse m'a glissé dans la
désorganisation de cette ville ça vous
paraît fou quand vous habitez paris ou
dans n'importe quelle ville gérée par la
droite ou par la gauche d'un ce pays
les choses se passent généralement bien
là et on le voit les maires en sortant
sont très souvent plébiscités mais à
marseille on est dans une autre
situation je pense que le résultat de ce
soir est aussi la fonction de cela en
tous les cas patrick mennucci beaucoup
de monde ce soir le report du second
tour de ces municipales 1 quel est votre
regard sur cette situation ce soir et je
suis comme tout le monde je me retirais
entre ce que disent les scientifiques
je pense que ce soir il faut dire des
choses m il y a probablement soixante
dix où 80 % des communes françaises qui
ont élu leur mère parce que dans les
petites communes
les choses passent au premier tour donc
je ne sais pas quel est exactement le
pourcentage mais je parierais que c'est
au tour de suzanne des 10%
donc à partir de là il reste qu on
consomme de communes qui doivent allier
merci beaucoup
il me semble que c'est peut-être
beaucoup l avance
il me semble que six reports avaient
lieu avec une date certaine organisation
sais pas lequel je jouais me paraît de
l'homme
et bien on serait tous capables de par
ailleurs plus là mardi de fusionner
résiste puis date ahmad repas menu
campagne électorale ségou six jours
avant tout une semaine avant la date qui
a en locaux la vie religieuse aura eu
beau mener sur le territoire national et
pour les mères qui ont été un élu au
premier tour faute il ment ils sont élus
je crois que les maires élus au premier
tour sont et il pèse quoi vous savez on
parle
sur votre chaîne et pour vous ce soir de
paris de mort celle de lyon de
strasbourg mais on parle pas des 30000
et 33 mille petites communes de moins de
2000 habitants
donc la plupart ont validé ce soir leur
mère donc le droit de ceux-là sont là
ils sont en capacité de faire
fonctionner leur commune pour les
grandes villes où nous avons besoin d'un
deuxième tour je pense que la situation
la plus simple c'est celle que je m'aime
bieber je pense que demain nous aurons
cette annonce qu'elle va me permettre de
le dire aux listes de se fusionner ce
déposé donc ça peut se faire avec la
mare du 18 heures de sport à chaud puis
on peut monter pour vous cette élection
c'est la prime au sortant on le voit
dans les grandes villes est également
effectivement par le moinde alors ouais
je pense que ce n'est pas que la prime
aux sortants et je pense que c'est il ya
eu une sorte c'est sûr mais il ya quand
même aussi manifestement il ne triche et
de la gauche
on nous avait annoncé une poussée des
écologistes elle est constatable
s'appelle en moi donc à voir là où il ya
eu désaccord socialistes et les
écologistes mais il me semble que il ya
eu le coup c'est la gauche qui a lieu
d'un semis parce que bon on le passera
certainement par ron saramba moins
content parce que nous avons la
situation du port en année on espère
quand même la république est en marche a
subi une défaite énorme alors les partis
au pouvoir sont toujours désavantagés
par les héritiers
nous avons quand même décidé d'aider des
personnalités je pense à strasbourg on
nous annoncer la victoire de monsieur
comme danone où il est kelly même
talonné par catherine trautmann alors
que avec 20% des voix alors que les
écologistes homme paumé de tête ou 28
donc la halle à strasbourg va
et à la gauche et aux écologistes et
donc oui il ya à lyon de la même façon à
marseille où le cabilat de la lrm que 7
ou 8%
donc c'est une sanction était prononcée
mais bien sûr monsieur macumba ne va
parler que du condat virus était
loisible à tous
nous sommes beaucoup que parce qu'il ya
pas de patrimoine en juin souligné car
c'est la bonne technique des big g de
personnalités socialistes soit françois
cuillandre bresse ce soit sylvain robert
allan ce qu'ont annoncé battu par le
front national qui est élu au premier
tour
stéphane le foll qui suit 44% des voix
olivier bianchi se calme pour ça que
l'as montferrand nathalie appéré johanna
rolland et bagdad je pense qu'il y alla
au parti socialiste une une espérance et
puis n'avons pas encore tous les
chiffres de la région parisienne mais
notre ami un bon teint et permettent à
saint denis
les cardinals qui lui avec cette course
à alfortville
david ross et délits avec 50e sonne bien
pour vous la gauche a gagné son pari de
de prendre ces élections comme une
renaissance c'est un peu ce qu'avait dit
son représentant et la république en
marche a perdu son pari d'ancrage
république la république marche a perdu
son pari d'un ancrage territorial et la
république noire font à ce qu'elle
mérite c'est à dire que quand on est
dans une situation où ekoko mais le
président a public est pratiqué toute
personne à un moment il est sanctionné
donc il y a en fait une poussée de la
gauche et mel tient là où la ligue 1
selon la mairie gardent leur nom et donc
on est à même de revenir une espèce de
2,2 scénario comique qui le scénario
gauche droite c'est d'ailleurs si tu as
passé à marseille nous a parlé au début
la république des masses est éliminée et
donc ne sera l'affrontement gauche
droite
merci merci merci belle amélie votre
goût rebelles merci bonne soirée à vous
merci pas au revoir et de son côté